day three arguably the most important
dates the day applications day of this
computational challenge workshop and
start off we have tutorial by Catherine
Ella from Duke University worked on many
aspects of applying statistical and
Bayesian methods to data sets types
today will be machine learning okay okay
so I'm going to try to talk about
machine learning in the health care
setting so I think in this in this
workshop we've heard a lot about
different inference techniques and like
how to scale up doing inference in
various settings and like this is really
to bring home kind of like why that's
important right like why is it that
we're interested in learning about
complex data and doing doing inference
almost of data to begin with and so the
first thing I should say is I'm really
not going to cover all of the machine
learning and healthcare work there is
out there there's less probably than
there should be but like there's really
awesome work by people that I'm really
not going to even mention so like Dave
and Rajesh have like a bunch of like
really super awesome work
David Sonntag you know like just a whole
bunch of people I'm going to talk really
about the work that I've done because
that's really what I know most about and
this sort of the work that's led up to
that that particular those particular
lines of work okay so this is my outline
so I'm going to start by talking about
some of the electronic health records
based stuff that we've done it Duke it's
a lot of time series modeling a lot of
guessing process based models for
looking at chronic kidney disease and
looking at sepsis I'm going to talk a
little bit about surgery we've been
collaborating with some people in
surgery off of data which is part of
like this national database called the
National surgical quality improvement
program and we've done a whole bunch of
things to try to predict surgical
complications in that setting and then
the last thing I'm going to talk about
which is something that I'm super
interested in is mobile apps in general
for looking at healthcare data so we've
done a project which involves modeling
kind of
like the spread of infection or
influenza within stored student dorm
social networks but we're also in the
process of building mobile apps for some
chronic diseases like multiple sclerosis
I'm really interested in kind of like
how you look at different sensors like
newer if you can call mobile phones
newer technology and looking at how you
can integrate them into the healthcare
system and then what kind of challenges
they provide from a machine learning
kind of inference standpoint ok so I'm
going to start by talking about our work
in chronic kidney disease and as a
motivating example this is a patient who
was seen at Duke
EGFR which is on the y-axis is a measure
of how well your kidneys are functioning
it's basically a linear equation that
people have come up with so GFR is
glomerular filtration rate and they can
actually measure your GFR directly it's
a very invasive procedure in terms of
your kidneys and they don't want to like
and they don't want to do that with
every patient but they want to get a
sense of how how well your kidneys are
working so that what they do is they've
come up with this
EGFR estimated glomerular filtration
rate and they calculate this by looking
at a particular lab value mostly called
creatinine and some other things okay so
on the y-axis is EGFR basically a
measure of how well this person's
kidneys are working and on the x-axis is
their age and you're going to see all of
these things on this chart ok so at age
47 this patient presents themselves to
Duke
they have untreated diabetes they have
high blood pressure their kidneys are
functioning normally but like there's a
little bit of evidence that something is
happening and the person isn't receiving
regular medical care at age 49 two years
later their kidney functioning is now
50% of what it should be at age 51 so
this is two years after that their
kidney function is now under 20% and for
the first time they're referred to a
kidney specialist right so
basically your kidneys kept like you
know can be functioning at 20% of what
they're supposed to be before you'll
even get the referral to nephrology
three months later the person presents
to the emergency room with kidney
failure and crash starts dialysis so why
is this bad this is bad because you need
emergency dialysis and so people have to
put all kinds of lines in your body
which come with high risks of infection
and other things and it's also an
incredibly expensive procedure from the
hospital standpoint it's one of the most
expensive procedures single procedures a
person can can have so they continue on
dialysis for the next ten years before
they pass away and obviously this is a
person with lots of problems but this
period of time right here the first few
years is a period of missed
opportunities right we had the chance to
prevent or delay kidney failure in this
individual and that wasn't acted on it
wasn't even noticed and we had a chance
to prepare for kidney failure which was
sort of imminently coming down the line
and the way that you do this is like you
insert you pre insert like particular
lines and things like that so that
you're in a much lesser ski
so forty two percent of people start
dialysis having no prior in a frolla G
care so that means that their kidneys
have totally failed and I've never even
seen a kidney specialist and less than
ten percent of people with moderate
chronic kidney disease even know that
they have it and less than fifty percent
of people with severe chronic kidney
disease even though that they have it
and so this is a problem and this is
something that we'd like to try to
address and one of the ways that we'd
like to try to address it is by looking
at things like you know what is your
EGFR what are your lab values so in the
long run I would like to even get rid of
EGFR it's an estimated it's a pest
emitted really crappy linear equation
and you can probably do better just by
looking at creatinine and other a lot
values individually but we'd like to be
able to use these measurements in order
to be able to create machine learning
methods which are able to predict what's
going to happen to somebody in the
future whether they're likely to suffer
from kidney failure and such
okay so this is where a transition to
talking about our work and how we made
an attempt to do that yeah the EGFR was
so low apparently they didn't take some
blood tests yeah yeah creatinine is
about just let this was just ignoring it
yeah so so let me go back to this
situation sure yeah so see this this
dash line at 30 that's a threshold right
that's when you're first referred that's
when medicine says to first refer you to
a kidney specialist at 15 there's there
should be another dash line that's when
medicine says to start you on dialysis
while you're up here this whole range
you can be tanking like what you see
nobody's paying attention because you
haven't crossed that 30 percent
threshold okay so what we want to do is
basically we want to be able to look at
a bunch of things like lab values and be
able to predict from this whether
somebody is at risk for severe chronic
kidney disease in the in the future and
so fortunately a nice model for for
basically a single trajectory so you can
think of a single lab value was given in
the shulam and sorry on paper that was
published at nips in 2015 and this is
basically as you can imagine a model
that makes sense for a single time
series trajectory and it's a guessing a
process and the gassing process model
has sort of a complicated mean function
where it's looking at sort of a
population effect taking into account
people's individual covariance their
demographics things like that it's got a
latent sub population curve so we're
going to say that the pool of people
with chronic kidney disease can be
broken up into many different kinds of
subpopulations and you belong to one of
them and so your curve is likely to look
like this right it's likely to go down
and then up it's likely to tank it's
likely to whatever right so you're
assigned to one of these subpopulations
and there's a subpopulation effect on
your curve and then there's your
individual long-term deviation so like
you as a unique individual how do you do
from your subpopulation and then look at
sort of like the variance of individual
transient effects through a standard
curl and so that was a really nice paper
and we decided to take that kind of
approach and look at it was it was
applied to modeling like sclera
scleroderma it was applied to modeling a
particular autoimmune disease and we
decided to look at it for chronic kidney
disease and the thing with chronic
kidney disease is that so first off
they're a whole bunch of labs right so
you need kind of like a multivariate
version right so we looked at sort of a
factor as multivariate version across a
whole bunch of different labs we looked
at this Gaussian process model that I
just described and we said okay well
what we really think is going on is that
people are having some kind of problem
right so there's like an under
underlying physical issue that somebody
is having right and so what we really
want to do is we want to look at the
trajectories of all of these different
labs and try to correlate them and we
try to correlate them in a couple of
ways we try to correlate them through
the long term deviations with a
multivariate normal and we also try to
correlate them through subtype
assignments right so we say you as an
individual belong to a particular
subtype probably or you have a
distribution over subtypes and we think
that your subtype is going to be fairly
consistent between different lab
measurements and we do that through make
sure multivariate normal okay so we look
at six variables of interest the EGFR
which I talked about five other labs
that are related to chronic kidney
disease we look at a cohort of 44,000
patients at Duke
we've got least moderate chronic kidney
disease and a whole bunch of
measurements basically again this is the
creatinine log value so basically our
goal is for each test patient we're
going to use data earlier in time to be
able to try to predict what feature a
lot values are going to look like and
then for each lab we're looking at what
mean average errors across test patients
and we're going to compare it to the
sort of totally not correlated baseline
gassing process version and basically
this is just a show this is a table from
our paper which basically shows that for
most of the lab values we do
significantly better by introducing this
correlation this shouldn't be totally
surprising right but like when you look
at at different love values and you try
to correlate them with you know based on
sort of like saying there's something
latent going on in the individual that's
a win another thing that we looked at
was chronic kidney disease is also
correlated with other thing so it's
correlated or causes heart disease right
so somebody who has chronic kidney
disease could have heart attacks they
could have strokes they often have
diabetes and so one of our goals was to
be able to model jointly chronic kidney
disease in the form of estimated EGFR
with these events these VAD events right
like heart attacks strokes etc etc so
our goal here was to come up with a
joint model of loss of kidney function
and at cardiac or stroke events and so
basically we did this through a
hierarchical latent variable model that
captured dependencies between the
disease trajectory as given by EGFR and
the point events that you know that we
captured through some kind of event risk
and we came up with a conditional
conditional basically a conditionally
independent joint likelihood model right
so here is the model for EGFR which is
the model that we talked about
previously and here is the model for for
the events that we're looking at like
heart attacks or strokes
okay and and like I said we talked
previously it's the gaussian process
model for EGFR and the trajectory of how
somebody's kidney functioning is doing
but in terms of getting the joint model
with with the risk of heart attacks or
strokes we're going to look at a pretty
straightforward point process model a
Poisson process model with a conditional
likelihood on events or and we're going
to use a rate function just the hazard
function at a Cox proportional hazards
model and so the idea here is that when
we look at the rate the rate of events
we're taking in information from the
time series model the GFR time series
model that we were talking about
learning previously right so we look at
its mean and we look at the standard
deviation basically and we take that
into account when we're looking at the
rate of actually having these events so
we're tying the two together in that way
okay and so when we went to look at the
joint model can we jointly model sort of
somebody's chronic kidney disease
trajectory with like their risk of heart
attacks or strokes we looked at twenty
two thousand four hundred fifty patients
at Duke with moderate stage chronic
kidney disease and more than attend each
EF our readings and oh okay sorry and so
we also looked at people who had
basically this is stroke and this is
heart attacks associated with their
chronic kidney disease paid cases so
about thirteen point four percent had a
stroke in seventeen point four percent
had a heart attack
and when we get is something like this
right something where we can say this
okay this is our mean function of what
we think that your your kidney
functioning is going to look like over
time and we can also at the same time
come up with a computed risk of having
any one of these one of these other
adverse events like heart attacks right
so here basically what we're doing is
we're moving forward in time based on
like you know and so we're conditioning
on everything to the left and we're
predicting everything to the right right
so as we move forward in time we get a
better a better sense of exactly what
the trajectory looks like but we're
doing a pretty good job of prediction
and as you can see once somebody has had
one event their likelihood of having
more it was up dramatically so um so
this is most of what I have to say about
I think about let me see yeah about our
work on chronic kidney disease this was
published at like you way I and MLA see
the machine learning healthcare meeting
and basically this kind of thing has
been incorporated into various kinds of
rounding tools at Duke and we've rounded
with it a little bit you'll find like
everything else in medicine there's a
lot of like red tape and bureaucracy in
terms of getting these into sort of like
the daily care of patients and I'll talk
about more projects where we've been
slightly more successful at doing that
but it's interesting because like
they're very keen to move to something
that's slightly more data data based but
I think in terms of things like this
they don't know exactly quite what to
make of it and so one of the things that
I'll definitely support is working with
somebody in user interfaces in order to
be able to come up with a good interface
for for our clinicians so moving beyond
just observing things
the cost of question of how does things
change when using TV have you thought
about that yeah yeah I'll talk about
that a little bit so not much right
because it's like a little bit farther
down the road from where we're at right
now but I think it's like a very good
very important question and so I've got
a graduate student who's very interested
in sort of like causal inference what
can we say about the causality of the
intervention on the the change
trajectory of the patient yeah no that's
that's that's really good I'll mention a
little bit going forward haven't asked a
related question are there interventions
in these patients that you were
analyzing no so they're all yeah no so
so straight up most most of the work
that I'm going to present here is is
really straight up prediction it's data
pulled from the electronic health record
system we don't really have the ability
to say based on what we're doing go back
into the doctors do things to these
patients in terms of you're forming a
prediction based on the idea that
they're going to march through life with
the same kind of rate of treatment that
they had before yeah I mean so yeah I
mean the answer is obviously yes but
it's not something that we have tended
to look at right like how how does like
you know starting somebody on a course
of antibiotics at this point actually
changed their trajectory what we'd like
to do I think in the final analysis
we're starting to run again to round
with with patients based on these
methods is to look at evaluating how
much presenting this kind of information
to providers makes a difference and then
how whether or not their treatment of
patients is affected by kind of like
what they're seeing and how much impact
that actually has yeah okay so the next
thing that I'm going to talk about is
sepsis and sepsis prediction this is
again like another thing that the
hospital is very interested in because a
lot of money goes into dealing with
patients who contracted sepsis to sepsis
is basically it like an infection that
you contract usually in the hospital
because through some sim line or
something that's been put in and it's a
very light life-threatening I think 50
people who
into who have serious sepsis it
basically ended up dying from it okay so
so what they use right now at Duke is
something called news and news is shown
here in this chart so basically if
you're normal you all of your all of
your vitals are in the ranges that are
shown here and as they get worse and
worse
basically you move from having zero
points to having three points on either
extreme and it's you add it up for every
row right so it's like if your
respiration rate is less than eight
that's three points if your oxygen
saturation is between 90 to 93 that's
two points so for a total of five points
that kind of thing and so again like
this is what they're currently using and
this is like a very very simplistic kind
of threshold based method I mean so
you'll get you'll get the impression
like impression and time and again that
what's currently being used at hospitals
is very sort of like threshold D very
kind of rule based right and so one of
our goals is really to see like can we
move away from that to a more - into a
more probabilistic setting and do better
and the answer is almost always yes
right okay and so there's been a bunch
of work on sepsis Suchi sarah and
company had a paper in Science
Translational Medicine which basically
just uses a straight up Cox regression
in order to predict septic shock there
there were some weirdnesses with the
time series aspect of that and so what
we really wanted to do like if you
notice this like there's really no
temporal component is to introduce a
temporal component into into this kind
of substance prediction and so again
we're going to fall back sort of like on
GP regression in order to to get a
complete time series right so we're
interested in being able to classify
time series with sparse and regular
sampling on some kind of common time
interval 0 to T and so what we have our
observation times T these are like when
labs are taken some observational value
to me these are like the values of the
labs and some reference times X so you
need a way of relating one time series
to another right which means that you
have to look at the latent function at
the same basically at the same at the
same time right and that might not be
the time when the lab is taken between
between okay so we're going to represent
a particular time series by its marginal
posterior a tax at a reference time X
and so basically we're going to use a
Gaussian process regression or say this
is the original Marlin news 2016 paper
they use a gas new guessing process
regression with zero mean and some set
of set of parameters the kernel
parameters and noise parameters and so Z
so your predicted function is random so
you can use an expected loss with
respect to a Gaussian process posterior
right so you have basically the idea is
you have this function you have this
function for like lab values over time
and what you want at the end is like a
classification system is this person
likely to have sepsis or not have sepsis
and so the idea is that you take the
output from what you expect these this
person's directory to be like in terms
of their lot values and you feed it into
a classification system and basically
you try to classify like this this is
this person that high-risk or not for
for sepsis through the classifier
okay so GP then classifier okay so so
we're going to learn the gas to process
parameters and classifier parameters and
to end using this particular loss
function so we're going to look at
minimizing the expected loss with
respect to the gas you process
parameters and the parameters of our
classifier
where the loss is given by the function
value so like the lab value going
forward combined with a classifier then
fed into the classifier right so do we
have the right label or not and so in
order to calculate this basically we
need to be able to take gradients of
this expectation right and basically we
use the same reaper ammeter is a ssin
trick that they use and say like quema
and Welling right that for VA es in
order to to to translate gradients of an
expectation and to expectation over
gradient and then we approximate the
intractable expectation with a few Monte
Carlo samples and then we use other
things in order to to speed up this kind
of optimization inference right so
conjugate gradients to compute the GP
means and covariances and the like sauce
method in order to efficiently draw
samples from the GP and then we can do
back prop in order to do and to end
learning through a classifier a GP
combined with a classifier yeah the
predictions is like does this person
have sepsis or not is this person at
risk of having acceptance or not yes
yeah so the disease is captured by lab
values and advised right so so sorry
so what I showed here in the chart all
of these things all of these vitals are
things that will will be fed in in terms
of like you know this is a time series
that we're going to look at that we
think is related to predicting whether
or not you have sepsis and then we're
going to feed other things into the
classifier as well like when was the
last time this particular measurement
was looked at because that's important
also but the main thing that we're going
to feed into the classifier is is this
function value
okay so what we do is again we have a
similar setup but we now have a
multivariate time series so we have a
time series basically for each one of
those vitals each one of the law of
values that got taken these are highly
variable in length a bunch are less than
12 hours long some are more than 10 days
long and so what we want to do is we
want to be able to use this clinical
time series baseline covariates
types of medications that were given to
patients in order to be able to predict
does this person have stuff to the
certain I'll have subs this and so
instead of having a zero-mean function
we have a mean function which depends on
like the medications that are given to
the patient right so we look at sort of
this is like an exponential exponential
decay on you know was this was this
medication given sort of recently if so
if so this is going to play a lot into
the mean function yeah
yeah so um so right so basically you
know if if some if basically okay so
when we actually go to look to look at
this this group of people right we say
everybody has at least a certain number
of measurements like in each of these
things that we're looking for looking at
when we look at like vitals because a
lot of this is actually vitals based for
sepsis right we're looking at a
situation in which vitals are taking
constantly basically for anybody who's
admitted to the hospital and so that's
one of the one of the nice things about
this again if I go back to like this new
score I mean you can calculate this new
score I think it's like once every six
minutes in theory okay so I'll get to
that on the next slide so that we also
redesign our GP kernel function in order
to look at sort of like covariance
between all of the time series as well
so we have a separable kernel sum up
separable kernels that we use and then
we use a recurrent neural net classifier
okay so this isn't like another story of
another patient who came into Duke so
this is one is a 37 year old woman who
came in complaining about complaining
about chest pains and this was a person
with a history of hypertension and also
of having a pulmonary embolism like a
clot in your lungs and basically all of
these things are things that play into
the different kinds of lab values or the
values the time series values that we
look at right pulse oximetry respiratory
rate temperature etc so again these
would be collected very frequently and
we look at how our method does in terms
of predicting whether or not the patient
has subsys and basically what we see is
that this is what the predictions that
we make are looking like this with the
red X is when the person actually
qualifies is having sepsis by the
diagnostic criterion they have laid out
now and so basically this is just an
illustration of so the person basically
this person sorry I didn't finish giving
the story this person it was thought had
another pulmonary embolism they were
admitted and they had it basically a
very a very very invasive surgery where
they basically opened up her her lungs
her chest cavity and physically removed
the blood clot and then she was admitted
from surgery she wasn't doing so well
she was admitted to the ICU and it's
unclear whether she got sepsis during
surgery or in the ICU but but this is
basically the kind of prediction that
that our method makes again this is when
she actually qualifies as having
substance by medical standards and so
basically this is to illustrate that we
can do a much better job of using this
kind of data in order to try to make
these predictions and sort of like a
principled machine learning
probabilistic
okay so the data that we actually looked
like overall I've looked at overall was
52,000 was 52,000 was from 52,000 and
patient encounters that's what we
trained on and then we had 14,000 and
patient encounters for testing there
were 31 longitudinal very variable six
vitals 25 labs and 36 36 covariates a
medication classes etc and this was
these were the results that we got so
basically everything that's a solid line
is our method and the left plot is area
under the ROC curve the right plot is
area under the precision recall curve
these are two different like curves that
try to get at the pursuit both the
precision and recall kind of concept a
little bit differently so we check them
both and so you can see like we move
from like a raw iron n to the multitask
gassing process RN n combination that
I've talked about we looked at and we
look at adding the medication of fact
which is the sort of the moving the mean
from being mean zero to actually
depending on the medications that the
person was given etc and we do better
basically every every time this lab
missing this indicator basically just
indicates how long it's been since they
were lost they were like they had a lot
of blast taken because that can be very
informative it's like oh no don't take
the person's blood pressure you might
kill them right like you know things
that are not necessarily causal as John
brought up right can be very informative
in terms of like how the person is doing
assigned in terms of how the person is
doing
so I don't know if I'm seeing the lines
right it is it looks like you need some
except very close
yeah so there when you look at area
under the RS you curve right it's doing
pretty decently right so this is ours
for a sub Society gnosis that's that's
right why that is I don't I don't know
if you look at the precision recall
curve an area under the precision recall
curve it doesn't come out nearly as well
right so this is just like differences
between like ROC and precision recall
curves it's just it I mean overall it
doesn't perform nearly as well at any
time point right like you can see here
but it does look that way there
[Laughter]
and so one of our goals is to is to put
this kind of like into a web app that
people again that people can use sort of
in clinical encounters where people who
are high risk for sex sepsis can be
flagged as potentially being at high
risk for sepsis and then you'll see this
theme kind of running through a lot of
the work that I'm talking about and then
like different kinds of treatments or
different kinds of interventions that
can take place and these patients are
suggested right so it's like if you feel
like somebody is at high risk of
substance you can send them to treatment
you can decide to start them on
antibiotics you can decide to like
retake a particular lab value in a
certain amount of time and those are all
suggested kind of like in a bundle as
particular particular things that you
might want to do so right now the
treatment for sepsis is very sort of
like it's very kind of like laid out
right in the medical system and this is
not something we particularly want or
have the ability to affect aside from
just showing this extra information
okay so so I'm going to move on to the
surgery domain are there any questions
about that
quick wait till you have a sense of how
that you use George look constructed was
was you know was it based on a specific
this one sorry
stable with voyages you know experts who
have a whole lot of experience kinda put
together something I mean this is this
is definitely like this is a rule-based
thing that everybody in our hospital
system uses I expect so that's that's a
good question and the answer is kind of
no right like I expect it's their
various boards like at the AMA and they
sort of like do a review of things like
sepsis and they put together sort of
like these kinds of rules and charts and
stuff like that for measuring for
measuring different diseases and they
get handed down to the clinicians and
the clinicians just kind of like look at
the rules and charts that they're handed
and just kind of like check off boxes
it's kind of what's going on right now
what what is it with you know a simple
structure like this what could potential
like it's a gated yeah yeah potentially
right so it's like if you want to stick
to a rule-based system and and this is
like this is something that like I've
touched you a little bit about like I
argue with about not argue but like I
discussed with people at Duke a fair
amount right like so one of the things
you want to do one of the nice things
about this is it's incredibly
interpretable right like you understand
what blood pressure less than ninety
means right
whereas for sepsis this is less true for
some of the other stuff that I'm going
to present but for sepsis like our
method right now is incredibly
uninterpretable right so you're getting
a predictive score out it's a-okay you
have like a 95 percent chance of having
sepsis or whatever but it's not clear
why it's saying that right you have like
a GP GP GP regression feeding it to like
an R and a classifier like who knows I
mean this is an issue that's been
brought up a lot over the course of time
that people have been presenting here
who knows exactly what's going on
whereas this is a very interpretable
kind of graph can we improve on this pot
possibly but I don't know because that's
not been what I've been trying to do but
I do definitely have an interest in
taking the kind of like GPR and
classifier framework that we've been
developing here and making that more
interpretable so you can feedback to
clinicians this is exactly why it is
that this patient is being flagged for
having sepsis here's what you might want
to do about this particular feature and
I'll talk about this a little bit more
so in surgery because we have a better
sense of exactly what features it is
that are playing into somebody having a
risk of surgical complication okay so
this is a system we've been working on
for predicting surgical complications in
patients going into surgery so there are
lots of different kinds of surgery and
basically I think 12 different kinds of
surgical complications that we look at a
poem
complications bleeding complications
etcetera so about 15 out of every 100
surgical procedures results in some kind
of complication and in 2014 which is the
last year that we actually have numbers
on Duke spent more than nine million
dollars in treating post-operative
complications right and so you can see a
few of the different kinds of
post-operative complications that
somebody can get listed there and so the
data that we actually use to address
this problem so I had talked in the
beginning about data that was pulled
from our electronic health record system
and the data that we have here is
actually in a sense it's better it's
called misc whipped data and the risk
witness clip stands for the National
surgical quality improvement program and
so the idea is that there are certain
variables that all of the hospitals not
necessarily all the hospitals but all
the hospitals who belong to this clip
kind of like feed into this database you
have a lot of data coming from a lot of
different hospitals
it's anonymized in the sense that we
can't figure out
unfortunately what hospital is providing
what data we know what data we provide
but we know what data we provide to the
Nesquik program
and this is just a figure shake okay
somebody had in 2016 somebody had a
Gemma article so this is the Journal of
the American Medical Association so this
is like one of the most high-profile
medical journals around basically
showing like oh like just belonging to
the net in this clip program doesn't
actually make your outcomes any better
and it's like yeah well you have to
actually take the news clip data and
like use it for something that's going
to affect your outcomes right but this
is this is apparently kind of news to
them so it got like a Jemma article
publication but yes so one of our goals
is to actually take this data take the
news clip data and use it for something
which is going to help improve outcomes
for patients okay sorry um okay and so
kind of the first one thing that we
tried was just a sparse logistic
regression model so we have a whole
bunch of variables the variables well
you'll see some of them on the next
slide the variables there are a lot of
procedural codes there are a lot of
things like how long were you in surgery
for etc etc and then we can look at all
of sort of like the complications that
you can get coming out of surgery and we
can look at the area under the ROC curve
for example and we can actually notice
that there's a fair amount of signal
there so if you look at like this
national database you can actually do a
pretty decent job of predicting whether
or not somebody is at risk for having
one of these surgical complications so
the method that they use right now for
determining whether or not somebody
should go into surgery is by looking at
the patient and going I think you're
good like you should go in right and so
this is literally what we're comparing
to right we're saying okay can we take
like even just like a very simple model
like a sparse logistic regression model
and do better than a surgeon walking in
to somebody to somebody's room and being
like you look like you can make it
through surgery to me it looks good
let's go
and so here's here's the larger amount
of interpretability because logistic
regression is a highly interpretive old
method right we can look at what what
variables are being weighted highly what
variables are actually playing into your
chance of dying or your chance of having
some kind of surgical complication and
basically one of the things that we can
notice is that there are some things
that we really can't do very much about
so you're diagnosed with esophageal
cancer we probably really can't do very
much about that right like that is just
a situation that you're in you're
diagnosed with having a nutritional
deficiency that might be something that
we can do something about right we can
call it a nutritional consult we can try
to improve your nutritional situation
before you actually go into surgery
right and so it's these kinds of
interventions that we're interested in
using this kind of tool to to start
employing with with patients and seeing
if they have an effect we haven't really
gotten there yet and these keep these
risk increase numbers these are over
sort of a baseline of not having any of
these yes yes yes
okay so I don't mean again what we'd
like in the long run is is for
physicians to be able to have a tool
that they round with patients who are
about to go into surgery on I'd actually
like to see kind of like my vision for
the futures to see this prediction
system which runs from their first visit
to basically their last visit and
predicts out to time after that they're
very interested in like whether they're
likely to have problems within the first
thirty days because of course like they
get dinged if somebody comes back and
like gets readmitted within 30 days
after like they're admitted for a
procedure and I'm not personally so
interested in that I'm just like more
interested in what's going on with like
the health of people but but in terms of
like what a hospital will pay for that's
definitely a factor so we'd like in the
end to have physicians rounding with
this kind of tool which tells them about
the different risks that their different
patients might have and gives them
options for what they might want to do
about it right now all the potential
interventions are being suggested by
clinicians in terms of like what they
would do to a patient if a patient is at
risk for a particular kind of kind of
complication and so here's an example of
a an app that we have this is currently
a functioning app that people are
rounding within surgery right now at
Duke it's fake data all of this is fake
data for like Tipper reasons and stuff
like that we can't actually give out
real data but so this is the name of the
patient this is the procedure the
patient is having so like a Whipple
procedure is a surgery where they cut
off part of your pancreas and remove
your gallbladder and stuff I won't go
into the details but this gives the risk
the absolute risk of somebody having
this particular kind of complication and
wound complication a septic complication
under a neurological complications
cetera and then they say what
percentiles are in in terms of like
compared to the actual population and
we've had it in the past so that you can
actually pull up and see the entire
distribution of people who get who get
surgery is that Duke and like where that
particular patient is fall
and then in terms of their interventions
they're listed here so a doctor can
check off say like the septic bundle and
then get a whole bunch of options for
what kinds of interventions they might
they might want to take given that this
patient is at high risk for a septic
complication again these intervention
suggestions are given by doctors so
here's an example this is the wound
bundle right so you're looking at right
here because this is more interpretable
this shows basically the kind of risk
factors that are going into this person
having an increased probability of
having this kind of complication but
then also sort of like a whole bunch of
common interventions that you might want
to take if you feel like people are at
risk for this complication
um okay so we've also tried to do some
more methodologically interesting things
with this data so one of the one of the
things one of the things that this
logistic regression runs off of is the
clustering of procedural codes and the
clustering of procedural codes right now
is done by hand it's just like a group
of clinicians have looked at it and said
okay I think these procedural codes go
together and this is what we've been
you've been using with our logistic
regression system and so one of the
things we've been interested in is can
we use like a clustering kind of
methodology methodology like a
hierarchical clustering kind of
methodology in order to say okay these
are the the procedural codes that go
together if we want to maximize our
ability to predict whether or not
somebody is going to have a complication
so we're looking at merging procedural
codes together and we're merging them
together basically based on what's going
to increase our ability to predict
surgical complications the most and so
doing clustering of procedural codes in
this way leads to a modest improvement
of somewhat out of the eight outcomes
another thing that we've been looking at
is transfer learning right so we have
this national surgical quality
improvement national database for
surgery we also know what data our local
institution is contributing that's Duke
University and so the idea is that the
patients that are seen at Duke are
probably not exactly represented in the
national database right like the
population of people that Duke sees is
going to be slightly different from the
population of people who are seen on a
national level across all hospitals and
so I have a student who's worked a
little bit on a hierarchical infinite
factor model for looking at doing
transfer learning between the national
data to the to local data so basically
saying like okay you know
can I can i down wait the national data
a little bit and up wait the local data
a little bit so that the national data
is giving me information in places where
I feel like it counts right and so the
idea is sort of think of normal factor
analysis the factor the factor loadings
matrix is chosen in a way that you have
a stick breaking prior and you're just
choosing particular factors that are
found in overall and the national
database for like the Duke data and you
could you could also apply this to other
hospitals right which would have its own
subset of factors but we don't have that
data okay and so what we found is that
was that doing this the hierarchical
infinite factor model improves our
ability to make predictions about these
surgical complications right doing this
kind of transfer learning improves our
ability to make predictions about
surgical complications off of just
looking at the national data alone one
of the downsides of this that we've been
working on the hierarchical infinite
factor model is that it's right now it's
just using some Sanders stamp sampling
methods right like you're sampling it is
not like that fast so so this database
this national database has about a
million people in it and there are
500,000 people who have you know data of
the kind of quality that we would be
interested in using but like our methods
can really only high handle up to
100,000 people right now and so we're
looking at speeding speeding this up
using like stochastic gradient notice
Hoover am i pronouncing that correct
yeah there was that simply
is that that basically the geography
follow what the high road sorry so the
hierarchy is okay so the hierarchy is
like you have these link factors right
and then you're going to say it at each
institution at each individual hospital
you you're basically you're pulling from
a subset of these factors right so if
you look across all hospitals you see
like a whole bunch of factors being used
but at your individual institution you
say you only have like a subset of these
factors which are playing into the data
that you're observing right so the stick
breaking prior is just allowing you to
have a varying number of these of these
factors right but you're saying yeah for
each local institution and it would it
would apply it right so if you were
looking at like UCSD or something like
that
you have a different subset of factors
then we would have a Duke right but you
could still use the same model
unfortunately I've had like we have a
hard time testing it because we don't
actually have the individual data I like
from UCSD right like people are kind of
limited a bit to their own institution
right we know what data our own
institution contributes the frustrating
thing is like misquote the national
search surgical Quality Improvement
Program does actually have that
information and they have actually
published on it but they won't like give
it to us right so this is kind of like
one of the frustrations that you face I
feel like when you're dealing kind of
like in the medical realm right people
are very proprietary about things people
reference HIPAA a lot as reasons to not
share with you basically okay so and
then I talked a little bit about okay
everything that I talked about so far
was was kind of post operative there
aren't a lot of post operative variables
we do look at sort of how long the
surgery took and stuff like that and
that's that's post operative but you
know my goal is really to create this
prediction model that runs from the
person's first visit through the
person's last visit and runs in
real-time through the person having
surgery right and we're kind of kind of
slowly making our way there
so right now we're starting to work on
the preoperative end and that's nice in
a sense because you have like more
leeway for interventions right that you
can evaluate and so one of one of the
things that they definitely do is they
they segregate people into different
kinds of consults based on whether they
think that they're at high risk or not
right so if they think that you're at
low risk before surgery you'll have like
a phone screen where they just give you
some information right but if they think
that you're at high risk they'll refer
you to like one of these clinics
depending on your age and so one of the
things that we've definitely been
thinking about doing is evaluating how
much impact those different screens have
on how likely somebody is to have a
particular complication coming out and
you could think that doesn't really have
a lot of effect on people's
complications but people's behavior can
vary quite a lot depending on exactly
what they're told and what information
they're given during these screens right
in terms of how like they take care of
themselves coming out of surgery and
stuff like that and so and then there
are other interventions after those
screens as well that were interested in
evaluating so that's kind of where we
stand at this point so going back to
John's question like yes we are very
aware and very interested in doing that
evaluation no we are not quite there yet
okay so how am i doing on time okay so
I'm just going to very very quickly talk
about the last kind of bullet point that
I had in my outline the last bullet
point that I had in my outline was
looking at like mobile apps and their
use in terms of incorporating them into
the hospital system as extra sensors for
better data collection for various
things and so the first thing is the
spread of infection and so I was
involved in a couple of loosely involved
in a couple of studies the first at MIT
the second at the University of
Washington basically where students in a
student dorm were given mobile phones
and like how sick they were and who they
were interacting with
which tract and this is kind of like a
dynamic Network kind of model where we
looked at can we predict the somebody's
likelihood of getting sick or
contracting influenza based on who they
were interacting with and their symptoms
right so we developed something I'm
trying to see if there's anything
important here No okay this is like the
social the social network of a
particular student dorm at MIT and they
reported symptoms like runny nose nausea
vomiting etcetera etcetera and so the
thing that we looked at using was a
graph coupled hidden Markov model and
what a graph couple Tatum Markov model
is is you take an hmm train chain and
you associate it with every person in
your network right so you have these
Layton states which are going to reflect
the person being sick or healthy you
have their reported symptoms
those are your observed variables you
take the chain and you associate each
chain with each person in your network
and you look at them interacting over
time and so whether a person is sick or
healthy in the future depends not only
on whether they they were sick or
healthy at the previous time step but
whether they interacted with people who
are sick or healthy right so you could
imagine that if you've interacted a lot
with sick people your chances of having
contracted an illness like that like the
flu goes up dramatically
and this is basically to say inference
in a couple days very hard so it's like
if it's fully coupled if you have a
fully connected yeah interaction it's
tracked it's tracked
h given so so like one of the
interesting things you could think about
in terms of future work is like can we
predict it if you've got like 10% of
your links missing and probably the
answer is yes we've never tried to do
that right but but yes we're
conditioning on that like we get that
data from mobile phone and Bluetooth
devices actually the number of nodes
that define the network is also an
unknown here yeah for the dog yes it is
known but the interaction the true
number of nodes in the network yeah no
that's right so we have parameters well
okay one second
okay so inference in this model can be
very difficult right if it's like fully
connected like there's no there's no
good way of doing of doing inference so
basically we rely on the fact that this
is actually very sparse your chance of
meeting somebody else is is very small
and also we end up piping through a very
small number of parameters and these
parameters are kind of the parameters
that I wanted to talk about with you
because there's a recovery parameter and
there's like did I get infected by
somebody else in my social network kind
of parameter but then there's also like
did I get infected by somebody outside
the network because there's always a
chance of that so we're trying to look
at sort of like as tight a network as we
can when we look at student dorms you
know in terms of people who are going to
interact with each other instead of
other people as much as possible that's
pretty much as good as we can get but
that yeah yeah no that's certainly like
an issue and so what we're comparing to
here is really like standard
epidemiological models which just look
sort of at a population level and say
okay you know half of my population is
sick what do I think given the recovery
rate
given the infection rate what do I think
my my population is going to look like
sort of in the next time step right so
it's not doing any kind of individual
level prediction where you're looking at
sort of like who people are interacting
with and that's really what we were
going after here can we do this kind of
individual level prediction okay so this
is a heat map so on the x-axis is time
on the y-axis students and so the black
dots reflect how many symptoms the
student is reporting on that day and
then the heat map reflects the
predictions that our model is making and
there is no ground truth for this one
but hopefully you can see that like our
predictions of illness line up pretty
well with the black dots one of the
things that happens when somebody
becomes sick is they stop filling out
their surveys right like it makes sense
I'm sick like I'm not going to fill out
my service anymore right and when that
happens what you get are like these
empty these empty boxes the person
didn't fill out their surveys that day
and so our algorithm is like also able
to infer that the person is still sick
even though they're not not filling out
their surveys so something more
complicated than just a reflection of
the black dot is going on that's my
point
okay so when I looked at the University
of Michigan data it was a little bit
better because Alison who's my
epidemiological collaborator actually
worked for the CDC for a while and the
CDC was co-funding it and so basically
whenever somebody whenever somebody sort
of like reported flu symptoms the CDC
swooped in and swab their mouth in their
nose and stuff like that so we know
exactly what people had like what type
of fluid you have like what type of
disease so there's ground truth for that
we looked at the hierarchical case in
this case so we were saying okay
individual students have covariance
sleeping drinking smoking hand-washing
etc that we think affects their rates of
recovery or getting infected and we're
going to look for ways of incorporating
sort of like the individual
level covariates that students have into
this model and these are the results
that we got I mean so basically just
saying now we have grunt truth and we
can compute precision and recall and see
that we're doing a pretty good job of
like being able to predict who's sick
and who's not sick we can also see
things that see like sleep quality and
alcohol uses playing into people's
having a longer every time and being
more likely to be infected and these are
just sort of pictures of the graph in
the graph over time as you can see it's
really sparse I wanted to so in terms of
inference because this is an inference
based workshop we did a lot of Gibbs um
work that is not super fast but we've
got a couple of papers follow-up papers
to this work basically using stochastic
variational Bayes there's a lot of use
of stochastic variational Bayes in order
to try to try to do larger scale kind of
inference and a lot of these models okay
and then the last thing I wanted to talk
about really briefly will you put in
interesting transitions okay was so
there's no machine learning here but I
just wanted to mention it cuz we're
about to release this app in a month and
hopefully will do really cool machine
learning and learn a lot about the
disease but something like this should
be happening for every chronic illness
out there so the idea is that we're
looking at multiple sclerosis patients
they have a lot of different symptoms
and a lot of stuff is going on and we
don't know anything about it because no
data is actually being collected in
clinic even in clinic in the once every
three or four month kind of outpatient
visits right now it's a very complicated
disease and so we asked how can we
monitor this more continuously in order
to start making better sense of of
what's actually going on and so what we
did is we developed an app and the app
has lots of things that
hopefully hopefully we'll make it we'll
make it a good mechanism for collecting
collecting information about about this
particular chronic illness so it's got
an embedded consent process disease
history surveys various surveys about
like what your symptoms are like and
what your medication use is like and
different kinds of activities so there's
like a finger tapping activity there's
like a spatial memory kind of activity
there's like a can you do serial
addition well kind of activity if
anybody is interested I can show you
what on my phone there's a pairing
basically through healthkit with your
like fitness tracker or just using your
phone as your fitness tracker to
incorporate information about like the
number of steps that you're taking your
sleep quality etcetera etc this is all
coming in as data we're trying to make
it really low work for the person who's
using the app right so it's like if
nothing's changed they can just force
touch their notification and say
nothing's changed it will repopulate
automatically with the previous day's
data they can look at the app and see
what different symptoms and tasks
performance has been like over the
course of like a month or they can
change that time period a little bit
they have a medication calendar where
they can say if they missed medications
they get once a week reports about what
has been their worst symptom they have
reports they can show their physician
about what things have been like for
them in the time period between when the
physician has seen them what symptoms
they've been suffering from
etcetera etcetera there's like a learn
more section where if they're having a
problem with a particular with a
particular symptom they can go to learn
more section and figure out more about
it and figure out what medications have
what side effects and what they do for
you and there's there are a lot of
places that we can go from here right so
we can use a lot of the kind of GP
models that
talked about in order to model the
progression of the disease over time we
can look at subpopulations based on
symptoms so like for example if you're
feeling fatigued right that could be
because your disease is causing you to
be fatigued it could be because you're
on a particular medication that's
causing you to be fatigued
it could be because you're like
depressed and that's causing you to be
fatigued and to try to separate that out
is really important and we can use some
standard clustering methods and maybe
more advanced clustering methods in
order to try to determine that and then
again there's this sort of perpetual
issue of evaluating the causal
relationship between different
interventions that get taken and the
effect on the longitudinal models in the
clinical and then the very last thing I
wanted to bring up was so in this talk
I've talked a lot about joint modeling
and so we're interested in in modeling
jointly the data that we collect from
this app with things like MRI images
which is what your clinician collects or
omics information that we also have
access to so I'm working with like
clinician obviously undeveloped in this
okay so I wanted to say thanks to my
students so there's Joe Fuu Toma and
he's done a lot of the work on the
subsys and chronic kidney disease work
that I've talked about liz has really
been heading up the surgery work that
I've been talking about and kaya did a
lot of work on influenza
I have not bothered any of my students
yet with the last thing that I talked
about because we haven't actually
started during machine learning it so
thanks
[Applause]
with the with the app pop is there any
yeah so so I mean there's a lot there's
a lot embedded in the content process
right so you can choose who you want to
share your data with do you just want to
share it with the researchers who are
doing this study do you want to share it
more broadly with other researchers and
give us permission to give it to them do
you want to be able to make your data
publicly available so it's like if you
talk to like some of the other I won't
go into details some of the other
machine learning healthcare researchers
right they're like very big proponents
of open data and being able to put your
data online and I think that's great and
I think that's a great way to learn more
about the data I do not pretend that I
am the be-all and end-all of machine
learning analysis of this data to any
degree and so I would prefer that but
that's something that somebody has to
consent to and I think a lot of people
actually will consent to it when I talk
to people who are involved in like
startups to reduce healthcare bills and
stuff like that they're like the vast
majority of people are actually not very
sensitive about their medical
information as long as you're protecting
them from like pre-existing conditions
and stuff like that that's currently
going on oh my god yes I respect this
has been half my life over like the last
year has been submitted a IRB protocols
and then going through different
security kinds of things at Duke about
like where you store your data and then
the reason this app is not out yet is
because we were contracting with IBM
Watson health cloud to do the backend
basically for data storage and like they
couldn't reach an agreement with Duke
over liability and data access and stuff
like that so we had to pull out from
that and so now we're going to probably
store data on like Amazon like AWS but
Duke won't sign a contract directly with
Amazon so we have to go through a third
party in order to make that you have no
idea like like
yeah I'm sorry yeah because they start
ups they're much more flexible to the
vagaries of University's contractual
procedures yeah yeah yeah and I mean
that's that's an effect what's going on
right so so these startups are often
taking something like Amazon they're
siphoning off a piece of it they're
saying we're going to run some extra
sweeps of like HIPAA compliant
protection and then sign a liability
agreement that at least Duke thinks it's
not going to get Amazon to sign and
that's that's exactly what's going on
I don't know whether that's a good or a
bad thing at the end of the day I kind
of just wish Duke would sign an
agreement with Amazon and call it a day
but like so you're sharing these
predictive models with doctors are the
doctors at all sharing them with their
patients um I mean yeah that's a good
question so I would say not yet but that
that's definitely a goal right so like
one of the things so it's like if you're
at risk for a surgical complication
that's something you should know and be
able to make a decision about before
saying that you can sent to surgery
right like it's like if we think that
you are going to be a high risk for like
a bleeding complication you should be
able to evaluate whether or not you want
the surgery kind of like based on that
and so that is our long-term goal at but
that we are really just starting to
introduce it to clinicians so we're just
too early for that but yeah no I totally
agree that should be happen a regular
loan
[Applause]